this is a really difficult question to
ask but it is the best question you can
ask yourself i don't need to tell you
who he is because his reputation
precedes himself i enjoyed being a monk
as much as i enjoy understanding media
and that's really paradoxical for a lot
of people but that's just my truth i've
always wanted to
share meditation at scale with the world
if you just keep trying to change your
environment hoping that your life's
going to improve you're going to feel
dissatisfied at the next place and i
feel we're just conditioned to say okay
you don't like your job quit your job
you don't like your relationship quit
your relationship and i think we just
keep saying that it's this external
shell that we're in when it's actually
this shell and what's happening inside
of it that's defining all of these
perspectives i believe that to create
happiness
day to day in one year in one month in a
week you have to have
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much jay shetty is
a household name all around the world
he is someone that's provided
inspiration
wisdom and insight to billions of people
using social media
i don't need to tell you who he is
because his reputation precedes himself
in his early years he was lost becoming
a monk helped him to find himself
and through service he's gone on to
touch the lives of billions of people
through social media
but who is he really
who's the guy behind the following
me and jay have a connection that i'm
yet to experience with pretty much any
guest that sat here with me and i know
you're gonna feel that today this is a
truly special honest open conversation
between two men about so many things
that i genuinely think the world needs
to hear
thank you jay and when i say thank you
to jay you're going to understand why
shortly
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the director ceo
i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
jay
first of all you know i usually start
this podcast in a much more serious way
but it's good to see you back in the uk
mate it's good to see you and i was just
saying this to you offline that i think
the first time we met was around three
years ago three or four years ago in new
york
and i think we have this plan to become
best friends
we're like we're going to see each other
this this is this and then all of a
sudden i moved to l.a yeah and then you
moved back to london too yeah it's so
good to see you man no it's great to be
reunited i do feel like we've got so
much in common in so many unbelievable
ways but the reason why i was so excited
by this conversation is because we've
also got so many we've walked a
different path in our lives um
and you're such an uh a self-aware sort
of self-analytical human being so the
wisdom that i've gained from watching
you online over the years is someone
that comes from london is from the uk as
well and is speaking to the world
through their content and channels i
find i found truly inspirational
so let's get into it
so one of the things i always start with
with people and i think this comes from
my experience with like studying
childhood psychology is trying to
understand what it was in their early
years that that has led them
to go on the path they went on and
ultimately to be sat here when you look
back at those early years in your life
in growing up in london um what were the
formative things that
you point at in hindsight and go do you
know i wouldn't be who i am now a bit of
an anomaly if that hadn't happened
i think one of the biggest things would
be that
i felt
i mediated my parents marriage when i
was younger and so i was their go-to
person
for my mom and my dad
and i have a really good relationship
with both of them
and loved them both
and they would come to me with their
challenges and their issues and their
pain points
and as i was growing up i felt that i
was always trying to reconcile
discuss
converse negotiate for both of them on
either side
and one thing i realized very early on
as a young child was i never wanted to
take a side i never wanted to
make one of them win and one of them
lose i never saw one of them right and
one of them wrong
i really saw them both
as two humans
who were trying their best but just like
me
were naturally flawed and fallible and
made mistakes
and i think that gave me a sense of
compassion
that runs through to today for myself
and for others and for people that i
work with and the people that we
communicate through
the podcast and videos
because i just saw very early on in my
life that people could mean well
people could try their best people could
try to be loving
and share kindness
but they could still feel that things
weren't working out for them so i look
at that as a massive
moment in my past
because
now when i look back at it i think i've
i've just been doing this for so long
like i feel like i started doing this
when i was
probably six seven maybe ten years old
and so now to be still doing it today
it feels like something that was a
natural role that i embodied at that
time
and it's now a role that has evolved
into
looking internally for myself
also looking at the things that i
adopted from that time that were
uncomfortable and
things that made me question my own
self-worth and my own meaning of life
what were those things i would say that
for me i realized that we either try to
repeat
or avoid
what we saw in our childhood
and that happens either unconsciously or
consciously so you could be
unconsciously
repeating what you saw in your childhood
or you could be consciously avoiding it
and i found that there were parts of me
that were really great at avoiding some
of the negative things
but there were also subconscious parts
of me that adopted some of those
behavior traits that i only discovered
in the last two years
and so i'll give you an example with my
wife
i sometimes played the role
of
sacrificing
and over giving
but then expecting her to give the same
amount back
now the way i see sacrifice now
is that if you sacrifice something for
someone and then you want it back
it's not a sacrifice it's a transaction
you can't give someone a discount and
then ask them to pay full price
and then say it was a sacrifice because
it wasn't it was a transaction
and i saw that in my life because of the
way i'd received loved from extended
families or love from school or teachers
or whatever it may have been
i was loved in that way where i was
loved but then made to feel guilty if i
didn't repay it in full
and i saw myself
adopting that in my own loving
relationships with my wife with my
family with my sister and i literally
only spotted that two years ago wow and
i thought to myself this has to stop i
can't repeat this cycle
what is the work you do to spot those to
illuminate some of those kind of
subconscious
behavior patterns that because we all
have them going on in the back room of
our lives and our minds we have our
childhood
the lessons we learn and the limiting
beliefs we learn
almost acting as the puppet master of
our adult lives and so how does one
become get to a point where they can
spot that and go do you know what that
comes from that what is there an
exercise you've done is that you know
tell me i think the first thing is that
when you experience conflict with
someone or you experience a disagreement
or a disconnect with someone
our
society version is blame them it's their
fault they upset you they're wrong and
our friends will agree with that when
you go and tell your friend that so and
so did something they'll say oh yeah
well you know he or she is a xyz xyz
sorry uh xyz
the the the american spelling to his
time in america uh the the xyz of their
so and so they're like this they're like
that
and actually in that moment i think the
best thing we can do is
what's my accountability in this
what part of this have i created for
myself
this is a really uncomfortable difficult
question to ask but it is the best
question you can ask yourself if every
time something goes wrong
or something doesn't work out
instead of blaming someone else or
blaming yourself
if you can pause
and say what part of this
am i responsible for and i think the
reason why that's difficult is because
we see everything as binary we see it as
it's either their fault or it's all my
fault it's all your fault or it's all my
fault and the truth is there is no all
it's all parts it's partly your fault
and it's partly my fault but if i don't
understand what my part to play is
then i can't actually understand it so
the first step is what's my part that's
the first part of the exercise
the second part of the exercise is now
that i know what my part is
let me focus on what skill i'm missing
let me focus on what growth i haven't
had let me focus on what part of my life
feels incomplete that makes me act in my
incomplete way with others so what part
of me is missing and i found that when i
was over sacrificing or over giving
that's because i was trying to demand
love from someone else and demand
validation from someone else so i was
almost trying to achieve or earn that
love and validation
and so i realized i wasn't giving it to
myself
and so now i've realized that whatever
you want from someone else
give it to yourself first if you want
compliments from someone else give them
to yourself first if you want validation
from someone else give it to yourself
first because no matter how many of them
they give you
if you never gave it to yourself in the
first place
it will never be enough so that's the
second step whatever you want from
someone else give it to yourself first
and the third step i'd say to get to
that self-awareness
is simply sitting down and plotting the
three most difficult times in your life
so sit down and write down what have
been the three most difficult times in
my life for the most
painful
decision making
points of transition in my life
and then ask yourself when you made good
decisions
what was the environment like
who were you listening to
what were people saying around you
and when you made poor decisions what
was the environment like what were
people saying who were you listening to
and you'll start to spot a pattern and i
found that in my life anytime i make a
good decision
most people disagree with me
i have to listen to my inner voice and
i'm usually doing something against the
grain now that's my pattern but everyone
has to find their own
you've reached a point of self-awareness
where you can literally pinpoint the
steps of doing that and obviously your
coaching and all the work you do has um
has exacerbated that extremely is there
like a practical day-to-day habit you've
installed in your life to be able to
look back at how jay's behaving on like
is it a notepad is it voice notes in
your phone is it meditation what is the
the day-to-day practice that's got you
to this point
so i would say that over time i've done
journaling i love voice notes because i
like speaking sometimes more than
writing but i'd say the biggest one if
i'm completely honest with you stephen
like sitting here with you and you're
looking in my eyes asking me that
question i'm like the honest answer is i
talk to myself a lot while driving
i talk out loud to myself a lot and i
will sit there while i'm driving and i
will talk through
that day
about a situation where i didn't like
how i behaved or a situation where i was
really happy about how i behaved and so
i'll pinpoint and i always think it's
really powerful to pinpoint
a point where you
were below your expectation and a point
where you were above your expectation
and i'll sit there and ask myself
why was it that i was above my
expectation
why did i have the ability in that
moment to act in that way
i'll give an example of where i was
below my expectation the other day
i was going to play tennis with a friend
in the morning and i was running late
because
i woke up i was figuring things out that
morning i had a few work emails from the
night before i'm eight hours ahead of la
right now so i had things to catch up on
i'm running late to play tennis we've
got the court booked and it's only
booked for an hour so we might be late
something really insignificant by the
way
i turn up and
i meet the lady at the front and they
haven't been able to give me a
membership card because i'm only here
for 10 days and then i'm like here's my
membership number and and they can't
figure it out and they don't know if i'm
in the system and now we're getting
later for the court
and i'm holding my own
and i'm on the verge of just being like
get on with it like can't we
this is not that complicated
and i resist from that
but in my head i'm thinking why did that
even happen like why am i even feeling
the urge to put a simple person trying
to do their job why am i thinking to
release my anger and anguish onto them
and when i thought about that later that
day it was all because i was late i was
frustrated that my friend's gonna be
upset that we're 30 minutes late for the
court i was upset that we're going to
get even less time and i was about to
take it out on an innocent person who
actually has nothing to do with any of
it who's trying to do their job and so
for me
talking out loud
when i'm on my own
spending time actually now when i'm
answering a question
spending time alone
is the only place where you get to have
these conversations
and most of us are spending time away
from being alone because we're scared of
having these conversations i'm sure
you've seen they did that study
where they asked men and women
whether they either wanted to be alone
with their thoughts for 15 minutes
or give themselves an electric shock
now the
results will surprise you
30 percent of women gave themselves an
electric shock
and 60 of men gave themselves an
electric shark and the reason was
because they didn't want to be alone
with their thoughts for 15 minutes we
struggle so much with the idea
of being present in our own minds and
bodies and hearts that we distract
ourselves so really the habit
is being present
with myself with my thoughts
and working through
when i'm happy with myself
and when i think i could have done
better
you know i really
can relate to that point about
um
not wanting to be alone with with your
thoughts not from my own experiences but
because i've got friends around me
specifically over the last year when
we've been in this lockdown who have
really struggled and even over the
christmas period i've got a couple of
friends who really really struggle
because they are alone with their
thoughts and you've spoken there to the
value of sitting alone with your
thoughts and silence and
self-contemplation but what is it
in the human in a human that makes them
not want to
be alone with their thoughts why for
some are their thoughts so
such an unpleasant place to be
i think it's because we've equated
loneliness
and being alone
with abandonment
and those are two completely different
ideas
you can be lonely but that doesn't mean
you've been abandoned
and
we confuse this so much paul tillich
writes about this and he says that
the challenge today is that we think
that there's only one word
for being alone and we call it
loneliness and he says we've forgotten
about a second word it's called solitude
solitude and loneliness externally look
the same
but they're completely different things
and he says that solitude is the
strength of being alone
and loneliness
is the weakness and to me it's because
being alone feels like abandonment it
feels like everyone has left us it feels
like we're alone at the end of the party
and no one's gonna stay
we've created a
feeling of being enamored
and being forced to admire
being together
my other half
my better half
the person who completes me it's like
all of this language
is
phrased in a way to make you feel half
and incomplete
when someone came to school and they
didn't have someone to sit next to them
that person was considered the loner
if you had a birthday party and no one
showed up you were considered unpopular
all of our self-worth since we were
young has been defined by do you have
people around you not the quality of
those people not the depth of those
people not how much those people
actually love you just did you have
people around you
and so we've just been conditioned to
believe that being alone
means being lonely means being abandoned
when actually
being in solitude could be the most
beautiful thing we could do so it's just
as a society we've got to unlearn that
conditioning
that's made us forcefully believe
that if you don't have someone else if
you turn up to a wedding and you don't
have a plus one yeah that's like one of
the most stressful things for people i
don't know who i'm gonna take
why is it that prom if you don't have a
date
every single major life event graduating
weddings they're all based around having
someone else there
to celebrate you
why like why why why can't we just
celebrate ourselves
and i think that's where we've lost it
we've lost the idea of celebrating
ourselves do you think that i was just
thinking that thinking that through and
i was thinking you know if 10 000 years
ago on the in the tribes of africa if i
was without
if i was without a tribe i would have
been
um from a reproductive standpoint less
attractive no woman would want to have
been with me because a tribe speaks to
the resources i can provide in bringing
up a you know a baby for our family but
also you know i would have been in great
danger my social status would have
decayed and typically they see this in
tribes i think in monkeys where if you
if you fall out of the tribe eventually
you get sick or die
um so do you think that's a prehistoric
part of our conditioning or is it like a
social
new age social um
construct i think prehistorically it
makes sense but i think the social
construct has been that equating
solitude or loneliness with isolation
seclusion and separation
and i think we confused the two ideas
spending time every day in solitude is
not me saying to you
don't talk to anyone all year you're not
good enough right yeah and it's not like
me saying
spending some time talking to yourself
and being alone with your thoughts means
never go to a party or an event like i
think i just think we've got really poor
as humans as entertaining two ideas
that are supposedly conflicting but
recognizing that there's a middle ground
like we're poor at saying okay well jay
and steven aren't saying be alone or be
surrounded by people we're saying spend
some time alone and be intentional about
who you spend your time with and for
some reason the human mind goes no no i
think you're telling me that i have to
go live in a forest and be away from
everyone but that's not really what
solitude is solitude is i am comfortable
spending time with myself for a few
moments a day enjoying my own company
and speaking of spending time with
people then so one of the concepts you
write a lot about is this kind of 75
rule
um
people often discuss the importance of
the company you keep whether it's their
wisdom their attitude their positivity
their optimism whatever and the effect
that can have on you as a human being
what have you done in your life and also
what is the importance from what you've
experienced of surrounding yourself with
people that have
good values that are equally ambitious
that share a sort of similarities
as it relates to who you want to become
is it important does it matter i i think
one of the biggest mistakes i've made
and i think we make as humans
is we often look for
divinity in humanity
you're looking for that divine person
that has all the answers and that is
infallible and perfect
and when you seek divinity in humanity
you're left with
insecurity and anxiety
because no one fulfills that divine
search and so for me what i really had
to understand is i went down that road
and felt like i was let down and felt
like people
made me feel unworthy or unequipped was
i recognized that there were four
pillars of relationships
and they are care
competence
consistency and character
every single person in your life
is going to be able to give you or
should be able to give you at least one
of these four characteristics
very rarely if ever will one person give
you all four
and if you're lucky you might have a few
people in your life that give you two or
three so let's talk about each of them
care
my mom there is no one in the world who
cares for me more than my mom she would
do anything for me she'd be there for me
all she wants to make sure it doesn't
matter what i've achieved or what i've
done if she picks up the phone to me her
first question is have you eaten
what did you eat
uh are you safe are you healthy right
like that's all she cares about
now my mom isn't the person that i go to
for business advice
or she's not the person i'm saying
hypothetically that i go to for social
media advice that's not her competence
but she doesn't need to be she cares for
me and that's what i get from her
now let's go to competence if i'm
thinking about
starting a business
new dragon over here
right like you'd be a great friend to
call up you're someone who understands
what it takes to get investors scale a
business build teams manage
internationally grow scale sell like you
have that journey and you have that
network you have that career i'd also
care about you i know you also care
about me so i've got two out of four in
you and you've got good character
you don't have the consistency though
because we don't see each other enough
so
so three out of four 35 yeah 75 percent
and so for that for me is that perfect
example of there's competence there and
there is care there which is wonderful
and there's character there i believe
you're someone of good character and
that's the next one character there are
some people in our life that hold us to
higher values
they help us grow with greater integrity
they help us see things beyond what
we're chasing they make us look beyond
our desires and make us recognize that
there's so much more to life
and those people are massively important
and those people may not be the people
we see every week they may not be the
people we see every day they may not be
the people that we call up but you need
them as your compass the people with
character are your compass
and then finally you have the people
that are consistent you have some mates
that you just know are always going to
pick up the phone
you know that if you need to move house
you've got a family emergency you know
which friend you call
they may not be the competent business
advisor
they may care about you but they don't
care about you as deeply as your mom
does but they are consistently always
there for you
and that's beautiful but the problem is
when we look at our consistent friend we
think why are you not competent we look
at our competent friend we think why
don't you have good character we look at
our character friend and say well why
aren't you always there and so we're
always looking for which c they don't
have
rather than appreciating for them for
exactly what they bring to our life
you know i met your wonderful wife yeah
you did yeah yeah honestly
in a room full of hundreds and hundreds
of people if there was a light
like if she felt like a physical like a
light in the room just her energy was
just unbelievable and it's it's
remarkable because she she felt so much
like you in so many ways i'm guessing
when you're talking about that third
point about character and values and
showing you things in life that are
beyond what you might have thought in
the meaning of life i'm i'm you know
from my own 10-minute you know
conversation with her i feel like she
must be in that category right yeah
right i always used to say to people
like so people become friends with me
and i hope they like me and then i
introduce them to my wife and then i
never hear from them again so she steals
all my friends and i'm i'm not even just
saying that like that's genuinely true
she has stolen every single one of my
friends as soon as they meet not
surprised i can't
but yeah she's just i don't know how and
it's it's been interesting because my
wife has taught me so much more
about me
and life
than i ever thought a partner could and
it's because
as my so my wife and i've been together
since before my external career took off
and so she was with me
when i had no money no job she
introduced me to her family when i had
no money no job i met her parents i met
her extended family i had no career plan
so i've been with her for around eight
years now
and
far far before everything kind of took
off externally and
what was really really phenomenal was as
my life took off externally
i started to develop this need for
validation from her
for what i was achieving
so if i'd get a big deal
i'd be like look what i did like look
what i did like isn't this amazing
and she wouldn't be impressed by it
and then if i did something and it went
viral i'd be oh look at this look at
this like look how cool this is like
isn't this amazing
and she wasn't impressed by it and then
if i was on the front cover or magazine
or something i'd be like oh look how
cool this is like look look at this
and she wouldn't admire it
and for a long time i started to think
did i marry the wrong person
and i was thinking to myself did i am i
with the wrong person because i know
plenty of people who are telling me that
that cover's amazing and that video is
amazing and that podcast is amazing and
that person's amazing like
am i like am i not worthy of respect
and i realized
as i and i reflected on that as i said
earlier i was like what part of this am
i accountable for
and the answer was really simple
my life my wife loved me
for everything that came before that
she loves me despite all of that
if all of that was to go away tomorrow
she'd still love me
and i was like isn't that the most
beautiful thing
like isn't that what we all want isn't
that what we're truly craving is that we
are loved beyond our appearance our
achievements our ambitions
and our goals
and i had that but i wasn't seeing that
because i wanted to be loved for my
ambitions my achievements my goals and
so yes when you talk about my wife being
a light she's one of those people for
sure because she's been my guide my
coach my teacher without even knowing if
you asked her this question
she she wouldn't say that she was doing
it intentionally
but
she's been such a great teacher in light
in my life in so many ways and so i'm
always just trying to
anytime she annoys me i'm like there's a
lesson in this for me and and there's
going to be something really profound in
this for me because
she's she's she's cut from a different
class she's she's remarkable i don't
even know how she's like her parents her
parents are incredible and you know
they've they've given her a lot of love
and so i see that kind of flow through
her it's so funny i burst out laughing
then because it reminds me a lot of my
girlfriend
and i i've said this on this podcast a
lot and it's i've never actually
realized
the
kind of fundamental truth in um what you
said there
but whenever i talk about my girlfriend
i say
she doesn't really care when i if i'm
number one in the charts or if i'm
number one here or that the reaction i
get from her versus other people like my
boys is kind of a bit more mute yeah
i think maybe she just doesn't care
about my you know my like prefer but
you've what you've highlighted there is
in fact that is somebody that values
something else yes in you so my
girlfriend would be very very happy and
very very impressed with me doing a
bunch of other things that would maybe a
bit more pure in their values she would
celebrate those things it's not like
she's not celebrating me it's just i
don't get the euphoria from the like
number one in the podcast chart yes and
it's a question of values and in fact as
you say that's what we should all be
looking for yes but society has taught
me
that you clap when you get big numbers
on stuff or you go number one or the
bank balance is big yeah so
that's so interesting it's probably
i guess someone's going to draw the
conclusion from that they're going to
look at their partner who's been
clapping because they've got like a
promotion at work and they're going to
go you've got bad values
and not at all we should we should we
should be supportive partners about
everything that our partners do but it
is beautiful that
you get an opportunity to learn about
your partner's values by what they value
in your own success
and that doesn't mean that like you just
said like your girlfriend or my wife is
not happy when something goes number one
or does great of course they're happy
but there's something deeper than that
that makes them happier yeah exactly and
i think that's really special and that's
that character in that light
do you want to drink yes please
what is this
i know what huel is but i didn't i've
never had this before is this vegan yes
oh amazing all right
yeah i'll try this vegan gluten-free
it's like a
yeah all your nutritionally
complicatedness this this tastes so good
you like it yeah it's rich it's really
good for you it really is good for you
and when i say when i say that how much
sugar does it have in it i don't believe
it has sugar i think it has sucrose or
whatever the replacement is it's too
good to feel healthy well you know they
could have made it taste like nesquik
and they i've been in the boardroom with
them and they just refuse they refuse to
compromise on the the goodness
call all right
whenever you're ready
when i was reading through your story
and from what i've observed with your
story there was um some really
interesting similarities that
really reminded me of mine but um i feel
like are an exception and it's it's you
and you know what you said it before we
started talking
you said um
we were talking about various business
things and business decisions you've
made
and also you we were talking about you
moving to l.a
after just going there with your wife
for a week
and you said well it just felt like the
right thing to do we were there for one
week and it felt like the right thing to
do so although you were leaving new york
where you had all of this stuff and you
were starting to build um your presence
there
you used your your compass became how
you felt and when i looked through your
your history
from
your very very early days from a
teenager to school to university to
going off and becoming a monk to
getting a job at accenture then pick
getting picked up by ariana huffington
at huffington post and quitting after
six months because you're doing this
other thing you are a remarkable quitter
and you seem to be one that's guided by
this compass of how does this feel not
what will people think
talk to me about that and is that
observation accurate
it's such a hard way to live in one
sense and such an easy way to live in
one step
that observation i i never put it in
those words but i love those words and
i've heard you talk about that before
about being a good quitter and i love
that
i i i think what you're saying is true i
i agree with you
i've never articulated in the way you
just did but it feels so true
i from a very young age just felt
there was this strong inner voice and i
believe everyone has it this isn't me
being religious or spiritual or woo-woo
this is me saying that there is a voice
that we all hear in our minds in our
hearts in our heads wherever you want to
say it is it's there
and
the challenge that happens is in our
early years you're told to tell it to be
quiet so every time that voice says well
maybe no no no no just just do what
they're saying do what they're told
get on that conveyor belt
get on that assembly line
stick that bar code on your back become
a machine go be a robot and and it's
almost programmed and so that voice that
is not machine like that voice is the
human inside of us is being trained to
be a machine
and so we start treating ourselves like
machines
and machines you just program them and
then press enter and then it gives you
what it wants but we don't function that
way we're a conversation in the universe
we're not a program and so if you're a
conversation and you're an interaction
you're dynamic
that inner voice becomes so squashed
that now by the time we're 20 30 40 50
60 70 whatever age you are you can't
hear it anymore so you say oh that's
some spiritual mumbo-jumbo stuff because
i don't hear that voice
but that's just because we quietened it
so for me
even till this day and by the way i have
more things trying to quiet that voice
today i had a
conversation with my team recently
i was talking about a few new things i
wanted to try out this year and a lot of
people said to me they said jay don't
you think that's a risk to the brand
you've created don't you think that's a
risk to who you are and i said well i
haven't worked this hard to not do what
i truly want like i haven't got this far
by being someone else i've got this far
by being true to myself
so i can only continue to do that and so
yes there are things that i do that are
slightly unconventional for people
who've been monks in the past there are
certain ways that i live my life and
there are certain things that i enjoy
and i always say this i enjoy being a
monk as much as i enjoy understanding
media
and that's really paradoxical for a lot
of people but that's just my truth i
enjoy building a business and learning
about what it takes
as much as i learned trying to
understand how to meditate deeper and go
internal i under i enjoy and appreciate
what i gain from all these pursuits
and i see them as being this beautiful
you know beautiful
symbiotic synergetic combination of
learning and life and experience but the
problem is our mind has said no those
things are paradoxical that's an
oxymoron you can't connect those two
things those two things are
unconnectable and i'm like
well steve jobs said that creativity is
connecting things and
connected thinkers will rule the future
so
if we can't spot connections in
anomalies
then i think we actually sell ourselves
short and so when you say being a
remarkable quitter i see that as me
saying
i only
have trained myself to know that i can
only do what i really feel like doing
with the awareness that this could be a
risk
but i'm okay with that does that answer
your question
yeah and you know you you brought up
another point now which i think is is
equally this sounds a bit like a pun but
equally connected which is
you know society will give you a label
they'll say okay you're a monk so act
like and behave like a monk we know what
monks are here's the instruction manual
of being a monk and if you do anything
other than the instruction manual there
then they'll say contradiction yeah
they'll say you're a monk how do you
live in laj yes you have a you have a
nice home you make money
and then and so what is what is it about
these labels that we give people and
then we society then tries to enforce
and if you step outside of the implicit
instructions of the box that we've
labeled you in we go fraud yeah yeah
what is that there's a really good meme
on social media that i've seen fly about
for years and it says society says
be yourself
and then it says no not like that
and i don't know who invented it but
it's been out there in in the meme world
for years and i love it because i'm like
that's exactly it and i the way you just
explained what you said i've actually
never heard it said better than that so
you've just explained in 30 seconds i've
been trying to round about for the past
three minutes uh but but that's exactly
it that we want to label people we want
to label things we want to label
everyone now let's take the rock dwayne
the rock johnson
we lay we could label him a wrestler
but that wrestler is one of the biggest
actors in the world today and forget
actors he's a brand beyond that
now if we labeled him as a wrestler and
said no no you just have to stay a
wrestler you never get to see this if
you look at steve jobs well you started
by making computers you're a computer
maker so just make computers why are you
inventing itunes why are you inventing
the phone now i think it gets harder
when it gets to things that are
spiritually intertwined
and i grew up with a belief for a long
time that if you were truly spiritual
you had to be poor you had to have
nothing you had to be completely
detached and disconnected
and i found that that's a worthy pursuit
and has some beautiful rewards at the
end of it as a journey
but i also saw having lived that life as
a monk that there were certain areas of
impact certain conversations that we
never got to be a part of there were
certain things in mainstream society
that we never got to shift and that's
something that called out to my heart
personally
where i felt well what if mental health
was mainstream that that was a
mainstream conversation that everyone in
the world had access to the tools to
help themselves for free through
podcasting through interviews through
books through videos through content
what if everyone in the world had access
to what i have access to as a monk
but what does that need that needs staff
it needs employees it needs eight
cameras it needs a microphone it needs
people it needs teams it needs a
business
so what looks like a business on the
outside is just purpose on the inside
but we're so
schooled and trained to judge things for
what they externally look like not what
they internally are
that we don't give ourselves that
expansive abundant mindset to say well
maybe this could be more now i'm not
saying that i don't have imperfections
and i'm not saying that i don't love
things as well like i i like nice things
i like nice clothes i like fashion i
like
uh i like living in a nice space so i
like i like nice things that i would
never shy away from that but i'm also
fully aware that i don't
depend on my happiness on those things
i'm not putting what i believe is going
to make me joyful on those things but i
appreciate having them but i've also
appreciated life when i didn't have them
so they've never defined whether i've
worked hard or worked on my purpose if
that makes sense 100 you know there's
two times in this conversation where
you've made points where where the kind
of conclusion that my head has arrived
at is we have to meet in the middle if
we're going to make progress the first
time you did that was when you were
talking about um having like an argument
with with a wife or a partner or
whatever it might be and you've got to
actually like meet in the middle and say
this is maybe where i can improve and
maybe this is where you know use step to
file and then you said it again there
with um with the example of spirituality
and probably like the business world
they're seen as polar opposites one is
all about you know maybe a less a
less of a desire for material possession
and attainment and climbing and
capitalism and the other is the
the definition of it and you're saying
well really if we are to spread the
message of spirituality around the world
we're going to need to learn a little
bit from the other side about building
and scaling and
and i just think that phrase the truth
is in the middle has haunted me for the
last couple of weeks since i came back
from indonesia because
um it seems to be the nature of
everything and we're actually moving
away from that as a polarized society
black white
police the people rich poor you know and
woman exactly
and and it's beautiful you said that
actually because the buddha always
talked about the middle path
so he called it the middle path
interesting for that reason from what
you just said that it was always about
the middle path that the answer was
somewhere i interviewed kristen bell
recently and she wrote a book called why
the world needs more purple people and
that's because of the red and blue
states so the idea of this idea of like
meeting in the middle that there's some
answers that you only come across if you
can
entertain this idea and this idea and
look for the connection and what i love
is that
for everything we're talking about
someone's thought about it and talked
about it before
and when i think of someone who defined
what we're talking about really well and
this is
a quote a thought that an insight that i
try and live my life by and it's from
martin luther king
and he said that the people that love
peace
need to learn to organize themselves
as well as the people who love war
and to me that's what's been missing so
for so long in spirituality and wellness
and health is that we can speak about
these things in this really organic
beautiful way
but if it doesn't get organized and if
it doesn't get strategic and it doesn't
get focused
it just kind of feels like splattered
paint
and it doesn't allow people to
practically apply it in their life so
sometimes when people say jay what
you're saying is so simple it's so basic
i'm like yeah i'm choosing to do that
because
that's what we all need like don't we
all need to make this really simple and
easy and practical i know that's what i
need and by the way i love getting
caught up in a heady intellectual
conversation and i've studied the vedas
that are five thousand years old and i
can reel off verses and talk about
philosophical intricacies but
i don't think that's going to help
people at this stage and that doesn't
help me when i started so for me i like
to focus in on how can we get focused
around powerful simple ideas
and a powerful simple idea that loads of
my guests come here and talk about and
it's interesting that they do because
they are incredibly successful people
typically um is this idea of meditation
and the power of meditation now i've
heard this word meditation for many a
year and increasingly over time i've
become more compelled by it and started
doing it thanks a lot to my girlfriend
as well
um
so
and you write about it a lot in your
book i mean a couple of the chapters
mentioned i mean pretty much several of
the chapters mention the power of
meditation
talk to me about this simple idea of
meditation and what the impact has been
for you and can be for those listening
so in the book
i present three different types of
meditation
that i was trained in as a monk and that
i was exposed to
and they are breath work
visualization and mantra so if you look
at all types of meditations that exist
today in the world there are three tools
or three formats in which you can do it
breath work obviously naturally it says
in the name it's all about your
breathing and breath work is generally
aimed at body
and physical so if you're having
physical anxiety physical stress if
you're rushing around your heart rate's
gone up breath work is a beautiful way
to come back into alignment now
visualization is really interesting
because visualization is used by
everyone from lewis hamilton when he's
driving his car around a track through
to david beckham before he took a free
kick visualization was the art of
sitting in one place closing your eyes
and visualizing
what's that track going to look like
what's that turn going to feel like
how's that ball going to move
it's visualizing the process not the
result and that's what's fascinating
western society has made it all about
visualizing the result visualize
yourself at the top of the podium and
the goal the smartest people in the
world are visualizing the process and
the work and the journey
and that's where manifestations gone
wrong we can get back to that and then
finally mantra or sound
so
the oldest text on meditation believe
that sound has the power to transport
and connect us in a way that no other
type of meditation can now we can we all
have experience of this when you hear a
song from your past
you're taken back there immediately
when you hear a song that has maybe some
ego in it or there's a song that you
that you listen to on your way to a
party or a nightclub because it pumps
you up and it makes you feel good there
are songs that make you feel violent
sound has the ability to wake you up in
the morning you don't wake up by sight
you don't wake up by scent you don't
wake up by taste you wake up by sound
sound has the power to awaken deeper
parts of us depending on what level it's
at so when you look at meditation you
have breath work you have visualization
you have sound
you can try a mix you can try one or the
other ultimately for me
meditation is an opportunity to build a
relationship with yourself that's truly
what it is to build your relationship
with your body with your mind with your
heart and with your consciousness and as
you continue to meditate through breath
work through visualization through
mantra and sound
that's all that's doing it's just
deepening your relationship with
yourself it's almost like saying oh when
i'm with my girlfriend or my wife what
do i do
oh there's few activities and
experiences that you do you go out for
dinner you watch a movie you go for a
walk okay well what do i do on my own
well when i meditate on my own i get to
know myself better and that's the
beginning of what meditation is but the
greatest benefits of meditation come
from using the right tool for the right
part of your life so before i'm coming
on a podcast like this or going on stage
if i'm feeling nervous or my heart
rate's going up i've recognized that
that's because i care it's because i
really really care what i'm about to do
and i want to be of service to others i
want what i say to help someone i want
what i say to hopefully start someone's
meditation journey potentially and if
that's the case then i need to be
aligned so i'll practice breath work
i'll breathe in for four and out for
four this simple practice just brings me
back into alignment
see stephen we all have this experience
how many times have you ever woken up
and you feel your mind is ahead of your
body every day your body wants to go to
bed and your mind is racing yeah or you
experience the opposite
your body
is racing and your mind is still in bed
so most of our stress
and tension in life comes from a lack of
alignment in our body and our mind our
body's racing 100 miles per hour and our
mind is slow or our mind's racing 100
miles per hour and our bodies slow
to bring them back into alignment you
breathe in for the same amount of time
as you breathe out
simply doing that brings you back into
alignment visualization i use for when i
think i'm about to start a difficult
journey and i think i may lose a bit of
patience or i feel like i really need to
practice this imagine this as i'm about
to go on stage doing something that's
really big deal and important for me i'm
going to visualize myself pacing back
and forth on stage i'm going to
visualize myself communicating that
message i'm going to visualize myself
being really energetic on stage
notice i'm not visualizing people
clapping i'm not visualizing people
saying that was amazing because that's
just setting a false expectation i'm
visualizing my performance being the
best that it possibly can and the mantra
and sound which is a big part of my
meditation every day i do to connect
with my deeper self i do to awaken parts
of me that are forgotten and
to
feel a connection to a higher power in
the divine there's so many people
listening right and you said that so
beautifully and eloquently um who i
imagine listen to me doing these
podcasts and they may be tuned in
because they wanted a business podcast
and they go here go steve again talking
about meditation or whatever and the the
react that reaction is probably caused
by
the
i don't know
the historic kind of snobbery that
surrounds spirituality it can be quite a
exclusive club right and the terminology
can feel very exclusive to normal people
and
chakras and all of this stuff in
alignment it can and when words like
that are said to some people who are who
aren't near the middle who are very much
at the other end of the spectrum they
just turn off to it so if i was just be
someone who's listening to this now
driving in my van on my way to work this
morning and i see a lot of people in
their vans driving listening to the
podcast um what would you say is a
really good just a first step to to
investigate for themselves
subjectively if um meditation can can
add value to their life where would they
start yeah i would say that the first
thing you want to do
is put something in your schedule in
your calendar which is time for you
if you look at your schedule you would
never cancel an important meeting with
someone else but we don't even schedule
one with ourselves there is nothing in
the calendar that time with myself time
for me time for you time for just
this this whole thing that's going on
right now literally put it in for five
minutes a day it's kind of five minutes
do it for two minutes a day just put it
in there because if you start putting
that in there you might then tomorrow go
okay well what am i going to do at this
time i've got five minutes wow okay what
am i going to do with it so start
putting it in there that's the first
step the second step i would say is
definitely focus on your breath i think
the breath is just something we can all
relate to it's tangible by the way
athletes have to learn how to control
their breath musicians have to learn how
to control their breath whether you're
adele or whether you're a football
player you have to learn how to breathe
in order to perform me you and everyone
we're all athletes in different ways we
all use our bodies we all use our minds
whether you're a business person or
whether you're an actual athlete playing
on a on a court or a pitch but he's
saying that i don't know how to breathe
i am saying you don't know how to
breathe yeah and not you specifically
i'm saying that most people don't know
how to breathe and i didn't know how to
breathe until i was taught how to
breathe and i know that sounds
ridiculous but how many times a day do
you get out of breath
i know there's times of days that i get
out of breath how many times of the day
do you feel that when you're
experiencing an emotion your breath
changes
like when you're crying or you're sad or
you're upset your breath changes when
you're happy and elated your breath
changes so our breath is connected to
every single emotion
so if we want to navigate our emotions
and our life we have to train our breath
so i would just say to everyone take out
two to three minutes and just take a
moment to breathe in and out and breathe
in for four and out for four just try it
as simply as that now if you're someone
who struggles to get to sleep which can
often be something that i think everyone
struggles with that's when you want to
breathe out for longer than you breathe
in so if you're breathing in for four
breathe out for more than four to relax
and rest your body and if you're one of
these people that goes jay i've got you
know i've got like you said i've got to
do a delivery today i've got to run to
this meeting i've got to get to this and
you need more energy
breathe out for less time than you
breathe in so you may breathe in for a
second and breathe out for a millisecond
it's a really sharp breath out and if
you do that you'll feel this pumping
energy in your body and so to me it's
these are really practical tools that i
think we all need to sleep so everyone
knows their meditation for sleep we all
need to get energized so that's a simple
meditation to energize and we all need
to just feel like we're not rushing yeah
so i think those are hopefully quick
things that feel practical to anyone and
everyone yeah i mean i'm i think my
natural position on things is to be a
little bit of a skeptic and i when i was
in indonesia the last time i my
girlfriend brought me to see a breath
work coach and before we did the breath
work he explained it to me and so this
is this is as a logical guy like i am
the explanation matters a lot yeah and
he was talking to me about um how we
pretty much live most of our lives these
days because of the over stimulation
because of the stress because of the
screens in this kind of like permanent
state of fight or flight and when you
look at what happens in fight or flight
and i studied biology i know what
happens to the body um and anatomically
and physically
what happens to your digestive tract and
i mean this is what a lot of people say
when they say i'm nervous and they've
lost their appetite that's your body
preparing and keeping
the minerals and nutrients it needs to
expend energy to help you in a situation
on the serengeti when a lion is running
at you that's a very prehistoric innate
part of our conditioning and we do live
on edge
our notifications run our lives and all
of these things so when we think about
why people might be getting a little bit
more anxious day-to-day
it's probably because we're living in
like a heightened state or fight or
flight and one of the things that
happens in fight or flight as well is
your breathing changes so yeah and then
i think about the moments where i'm
feeling a little bit stressed and one
thing i've done and i might find it so
funny my head went straight to new york
city as i'll go i'll stop and i'll just
go
and whenever i do that someone turns to
me and goes are you okay
okay i'm fine i'm just like i am now
yeah yeah yeah yeah but no i completely
agree and
i think it's one of those things that i
think everybody's listening regardless
of who you are or how
much of a tough guy you are you should
um definitely you're a tough guy stephen
so you know well not really no not
really i'm a bit soft okay you know
around the edges
this let's talk a little bit about fear
then because we talked about that there
in your book
in chapter three you you talk about
there being good fear and bad fear
how can fear be a good thing
i
realized that fear
could be healthy or unhealthy
based on how i used it
and most of us don't realize
that we get consumed by fear instead of
using fear
so fear becomes
our
being in the sense that
fear becomes what controls us it tells
us what we should do and what we
shouldn't do it tells us how we should
think and we shouldn't think it stops us
from doing stuff that's really important
to us
and it makes us do things that we would
never ever do it makes us say things to
people that we love that we would never
want to say to them and on the other end
it stops you from saying things you
really want to say to someone because
you don't want to appear weak and your
ego won't let you sophia takes this
really magnetic controlling effect on
our whole lives
but fear at the same time can be one of
the healthiest things because it's
basically giving you a signal
as to what's important it's basically
giving you as a signal as to how you
feel and when you use it as a signal
not as a
suggestion or a push it changes
everything so let's let's make that
practical when you are in your home and
if the fire alarm goes off
that gives you a signal to say check for
the fire check if there's a fire right
now if you go oh just turn it off it
doesn't matter let's let's avoid my fear
let's avoid it let's just turn it off
let's forget about it
your house could burn down or if you're
lucky there was nothing and it's fine
but the odds are that there could be a
fire
now if you're someone who goes well let
me inspect it let me be curious about
that i am scared that there's a fire in
my house now that i've heard the fire
alarm but let me be curious let me
inspect let me check
imagine we approached our fear in that
way imagine every time i felt scared of
something i said well let me get curious
about this why am i scared of this
why is it
affecting me so much what about this
scares me is it all of it or is it just
a part of it when you start doing it you
start to break that fear down and that's
the healthy way of looking at fear
rather than the unhealthy way of saying
forget about it keep it away from me i
don't want to go there and so for me i
really feel that
fear is what blocks us from these
beautiful breakthroughs in life
and it has such a choke hold on us like
it's such a strong hold on us and i
think most of us are living our lives
because we're scared of what someone
will say what someone will think or what
someone will do
and
that feels
like something that we're going to
regret when we're
at the end of our lives well they do
they do right so they interview people
as you know on their deathbed and this
is the number one regret of the dying
your dms they must be full of people
that are exhibiting exactly that
behavior because i know mine are yeah a
young person saying i'm in this job i'm
in this relationship i it sucks but
yeah fear right yes fear of change fear
of uncertainty whatever it might be what
do you typically say to those people
that you know
they hate the situation they're in but
the fear is kind of imprisoning them to
to into an action
i think i always meet i always i'm
saying this to someone on my team this
morning actually i i always try and meet
everyone
with compassion and not judgment
because i know what it feels like to
experience that and i still experience
that in different areas of my life so
it's always there and i think if you
don't meet it with compassion you can
kind of say something really energetic
in the moment and kind of make them feel
like they've solved it but that isn't
really wearing it down i think for me
the first thing is to acknowledge that
that fear is real to acknowledge that
there potentially will be backlash that
there potentially will be someone who's
upset because i think often we're told
oh no just do what you want and it
doesn't matter and i'm like well it does
matter because
maybe you are a good person and you
don't want someone to be upset or you
don't want to let your parents down or
you don't want to hurt someone right or
you don't want to
uh ruin your reputation by quitting your
job or whatever it may be
and i think it's important to
acknowledge that that's real and that
may happen
but i think what i try and do next is
say okay well let's say you didn't
change anything
how are you gonna feel in five to ten
years
and that's my favorite question to ask
someone let's not change anything about
your life
how does it feel in five to ten years
and if it feels worse
than what you think it is now
chances are that even if you're going to
hurt someone that's probably the better
way to go but if you say you're going to
feel the same or better
then sure just accept that and most
people will say well no if i if i don't
change anything if i don't get out of
this my life's going to be worse but
here's the other thing i think we're
always conditioned to think that we need
to change our situation
to create a change in our life
and actually with what both of us
believe it's all about a change in
perspective and mindset i have learned
things from jobs that i hated
but that are so useful to me right now
i have learned things from relationships
with people i've had and those people
that i didn't get along with but those
lessons are still serving me today i've
been in countless situations where i
wanted to get out that situation but
that situation was perfectly designed to
show me something and the problem is
we're constantly trying to just move and
get away and so
really what i say to everyone is i want
you
to find out
what is the perspective shift that this
situation is trying to create in your
life because if you take that with you
that perspective is going to stay with
you no matter the situation but if you
just keep trying to change your
environment hoping that your life's
going to improve you're going to feel
dissatisfied at the next place and the
next place and the one after that and i
feel we're just conditioned to say okay
you don't like your job quit your job
you don't like your relationship quit
your relationship
it's not the job of relationship it's
the way you see it and i think we just
keep saying that it's this external
shell that we're in
when it's actually this shell and what's
happening inside of it that's defining
all of these perspectives
so much i mean that was a unbelievably
beautiful answer and i'm gonna 100 still
that answer i want you to know
especially that five year point because
it is a really good sort of mental um
game to to role play um one of the
things i was thinking when you know you
were talking then is about a lot of
those messages that we'll get on
instagram wherever it might be they're
centered in insecurity some kind of
insecurity and because we have a lot of
followers you significantly more than me
and because we have a big audience what
people will assume is that we have all
the answers but we've got it all figured
out and that we live our lives like
saints and i always want to be really
clear on this podcast that i absolutely
do not
so let's talk about that how about we go
back and forward and we just say
a couple of things we're really really
bad at and we want to improve on whether
they are insecurities they are
lessons wisdom we know but we don't
follow et cetera et cetera you please be
my guest
this one's been the one that the
universe keeps teaching me so when if i
think about this question this is the
first thing that came to my mind
i
keep believing
that i'm going to meet someone
who's going to help me take my work to
the next level
and so i always have had this belief and
i don't know where it comes from it's
it's one of those ones that i still need
to figure out where every year i'll be
like oh well yeah yeah if i'm working
with that person that person like as a
manager or an agent or whatever it was
like that person's gonna help me get to
another stage
and the universe just keeps teaching me
every year that it's you it's you it's
you it's you like you've gotta do it for
yourself there's not gonna be anyone
that comes into your life and changes
your life but my naivety
every year
is to try and look for that person
and if someone asked me and said well
jay who's going to be that person for me
i would tell them
no what do you think it's you that's
what i would say to them off the bat i
would say to someone stop depending on
other people stop waiting for someone to
change your life you have to change your
life but then in my own life i keep my
actions show that i'm still looking for
that so that's the first thing i'm sure
let's go back and forth i like this yeah
there's there's going to be plenty more
okay so the
loads came to mind yeah so i'll just
i'll try and start from the top so the
first thing that came to mind that i
i know
the truth upon and i would preach about
this podcast but i find it hard to do is
i
still kind of impose my own bias and
beliefs on the world onto others and i
still loosely
don't understand why everybody doesn't
want to do what i want to do with their
life so i don't understand why everybody
doesn't want to be successful and push
and climb the ladder and pursue
and have nice things and build wealth
and build an empire so sometimes there's
this real bias in the advice i give
people and this real kind of like
naivety and lack of understanding that
happiness is the north star we all have
our own path to getting there and i can
even exhibit that as an employer i can
my a voice can sometimes question why
team members might not behave with in
the same way as me
and it's fundamentally because again the
north star is happiness and their path
to being happy is not the same as mine
and that's a really dangerous game to
play especially when you've got a big
platform because you'll make people feel
inadequate for their journey to
happiness because it doesn't resemble
your own
and so i really need to get better at
understanding we all have different
paths and if i just say to myself the
north star is happiness and we all have
our own ways there then i can stop
preaching upon people or assuming that
because they are not following my path
they are incorrect yes
yes i love that i think one of the
biggest things i obviously talk about is
asking people to take time for
themselves and make time for themselves
you already know where this is going
and and i think it's really interesting
because
i i think i try and i think i do but i
know that this year
when it came to
so i i try and take a full month off
every year for myself and usually i go
to india and because of covet i haven't
been able to go for the last two years
and i usually go and live with the monks
again and and take part in all the
meditations and practices for a month
and it's one of my favorite things to do
and i haven't been able to do it for the
last two years so i still decided i
would take a month off
and
it came and i said i would do from the
15th of december to the 15th of jan
and then i found out a week before that
i kind of had to stay for an extra week
in la for work so i delayed it and i was
like oh i'm going to do 22nd of
december to the to the 17th of jan
and then i i got to london i started
taking that break off but it was like i
got to a point where i could see that
i'd been delaying
my self-care
and i kept delaying it even by that week
and in that week before i left i could
tell
that i needed a break like i needed to
switch off and my advice to everyone is
don't let it get to that point you've
got to take it just before that and i
was planning on doing that it was
scheduled but because of commitments and
priorities and important things i had to
push that extra mile and
sure
i'm fine and i'm okay and i feel great
but i don't think that that's
sustainable and i think it was a
different journey
and and this is being honest too
i don't think i pro i'm a proponent of
work-life balance although it may appear
that way so this may actually be a
perception thing i think people may
perceive that jay believes in perfect
work-life balance and the truth is i
don't i believe in purpose and purpose
to me is being obsessed about what you
care about and what's important to you
and so for me what i do is my purpose
and so i'm obsessed about it i care
about it i love it i breathe it i live
it
and
when i was building i was working 18
hours a day
i was
you know
a couple of those were meditations sure
but then i was sleeping for six hours
but i was working 18 hours a days for
two to three years straight seven days a
week and i think the perception is often
people may feel that no jay you live a
perfectly balanced life and i'm like
well no no i haven't like to there's a
different skill required to go upwards
then stay maintain create momentum like
it's a different gear that you're in all
the time and so today my life is far
more disciplined in my health and
wellness than it's ever been before
but there have been periods of the years
getting here that didn't look like that
at all if that
thank you for sharing that yeah that's
super valuable um my next one would be
what you described at the tennis court
which was
some days especially because
i mean these are probably everything i
say now is probably gonna be an excuse
but i'm gonna say it anyway but i've
presented it as an excuse so hopefully
that kind of is okay
but i think i've geared my mind to care
so much about the like being time
efficient yes that in situations where
things aren't moving with the efficiency
that i
i i demand from my business life yeah
because you put your hand up here
that i might because because of my
expectations are of efficiency and speed
when i encounter a situation maybe like
the people that were bumbling around
with the clipboard at the tennis court
that you described trying to find your
membership or whatever
my expectation goes unmet
frustration arrives and then i might
compromise on the way that i behave yeah
and that might mean being abrupt being
too too forward with somebody or being
too too harsh or lacking compassion in
the way that i say something
people don't know this about me but when
i'm alone
i think about this it's probably the
number one thing i think about i reflect
on how i treated people that day yes and
there's been too many days in a row
where i've gone you [ __ ] that up again
steve yeah be better tomorrow and then
i'll come into tomorrow the expectation
will go in matt
i'll be i'll become a person i don't
want to be and i'll say to myself in my
private time i say you [ __ ] that up
again yeah and i've been doing that too
much for too long
i think we all have i mean i talk about
in my book i had this i had this moment
same thing as you just said i uh this
was a couple of years ago in l.a and i
was traveling around in in ubers and
going here and there and getting in or
lyft and calling one and jumping in and
going on and i got in and i was on my
phone and doing whatever
and then five minutes later i realized
we hadn't moved
and
and that's how consumed i was on my
phone whether i was scrolling or texting
or emailing
and i said to the driver i said is
everything okay and he said you didn't
say hello
and he said i said hello to you five
minutes ago and you didn't say hello
and i just it it was such a like
i was late for my meeting i was late for
a big thing what i felt terrible
i felt so so bad and i was like
i really want people to connect with
everyone as a human i said i'm so sorry
what's your name
like like and then and he started
driving and he wasn't trying to he
wasn't even trying to be abrasive like
some people say oh well that's a bit
he's not doing this i actually don't
think it's his fault at all i think he
taught me such a valuable lesson because
i was just kind of like oh yeah it's a
service i booked it treating him like a
robot treating him like a machine and
yeah one day we'll have driverless cars
and i won't have to say hello sure but
treating a human in that way
it i i think that goes against
everything i stand for is that i want us
to become more human
and i want us to not lose our humanity
as technology advances and i love
technology and it's great but let's not
lose our ability to have human
connection which is what brings so much
joy to our lives and so yeah i you know
that that's one of those moments that i
was like
you know you're really trying to teach
me a lesson here because
yeah you know what this this whole back
and forward if it's taught us anything
it's that even people that you presume
to to have the answers from the from the
outside
um in fact maybe the correct answer is
to understand one's own faults
understand we're all really really
imperfect to be self-aware about those
faults and then make a commitment to
being better every day i think i'll die
imperfect but trying to be better i
don't think i'll die perfect
and i think um i think that is maybe
there'll probably be people that view
the work that you do and say god he's
got it all figured out a hundred percent
of things and i don't so i'm inadequate
yes i need to be jay and if i'm not jay
then i'm inadequate i'm morally wrong my
value's about i'm a bad person
so that's kind of i love that i'm so
glad i love the back and forth too i you
know for me it's it's always
wonderful to talk about these things and
i think that's what our generation has
changed in this space because i think we
did live at a time when gurus and guides
and coaches were revered as flawless
perfect and you never really saw
the behind the scenes and i think i i
always say to my team like i'm always
trying to i don't want i don't even want
that pressure
it's it's pressure and it actually stops
you from being sincere and genuine and
authentic and i feel that pressure
sometimes like i feel that pressure when
someone has a question and i need to
rush off and i'm like i want to answer
it but i also need to rush off and i
feel that pressure
and it's just
i've realized i don't want that pressure
like because i'm not perfect and i don't
want to try and pretend i am or i don't
want to have to live up to it because it
will just let someone down and it's
really interesting because this was
around probably around 11 years ago now
and this was i was mentoring before i
became a monk when i was a monk i was a
mentor and then i became a coach and
whenever i took on a mentee or a coach
coaching client or anyone the one of the
first things i'd say to them in our
first meeting is i just want you to know
that i will let you down
i just want you to know that that there
will be something i do
that upsets you disappoints you or lets
you down
if you're okay with that let's get
started let's get going
and i saw the amount of people that
walked out that door really yeah there
were people that left
because they were expecting divinity and
humanity
and they were expecting perfection and
i'm really happy that they left because
i would never have been able to live up
to that and i don't even want the
pressure and so i'm really clear with
people even now like i work with so many
clients and that's one of the first
things i'll say to them and you see that
the people that stay recognize that
because they understand they have flaws
and we all do
and i also took off the pressure
especially in coaching where
a lot of people think you can change
their life and as an immature coach or
therapist you may think you can change
someone else's life
and the more i've coached and the more
hours i've racked up with coaching the
more i've realized
i don't i can't change someone's life
i don't have what it takes to change
someone's life i
don't have to say something profound
every word i say
and not everything i say is going to be
perfect and incredible and insightful
and if i can let go of that i actually
might allow something beautiful to
happen
actually trying to do all those things
trying to say something profound every
sentence trying to magically solve
someone's problems
trying to be perfect all of these things
actually block something beautiful from
happening kind of interesting because it
very much links to what you said about
not not putting the expectation on the
outcome you said that earlier i'm not
going to try and change your life today
but let's just focus in as you said
earlier on the process of like what we
can do today i guess part of my point
the first thing that came to mind there
was
we both write quotes and put them out on
the internet and that kind of thing but
i'm going to be completely honest when i
write quotes on instagram i have no
expectation that it's going to change
the life of pretty much i actually don't
think even if people agree with it most
of them won't actually do anything
probably over 95 maybe 99 of them
but what does it take to have an impact
on someone's life is it something that
you can do as a coach or is it something
inside them that is you're just the
oxygen to their flame what is it
i believe that we need different
language different perspectives
different faces different voices to
connect with every person on the planet
you're going to say the same thing
in your own way from your own mind and
heart and your experience and that's
going to touch someone in a way that
what i said can't and then i'm going to
say something in a context that's going
to impact someone else that your words
may not speak to because
i've i've heard truth again and again
and again and again and again
and then i hear it again last week
and it clicks
because i heard it from someone that
said it in a way that speaks to the
language of my soul that speaks to the
language of my mind and heart
and i think that's what's so fascinating
about needing more voices and more faces
and more people trying to serve but when
you talk about what creates change in
coaching there's there's four steps to
making a change in someone's life it
goes theoretical
meaningful
practical and applicable so most people
when they like a post on instagram
or maybe they comment
that's them saying theoretically i agree
with this and i understand it i
understand the theory that what you're
saying is true and i like it and i agree
with it theoretically but that
theoretical understanding doesn't create
transformation that theoretical
understanding doesn't change someone's
life it may hit them here and hit them
here
the next step actually is from here to
here which is is it meaningful to them
so i'll give an example let's say
someone reads a quote but they just lost
their parent
or they just lost a family member they
love
i know i've had that happen to me in the
last couple of years i'm sure many
people listening have
now it's not theory it's meaningful
because it's hit your heart it's gone
from here to here and you're like
okay that really resonated
but again that doesn't change your life
because now it's meaningful it's
emotional it's internal but that hasn't
changed in your action or your behavior
so the next step is making that
practical
okay steven wrote that amazing quote how
do i make that practical let me reflect
this is the work that the coachee or the
client needs to do okay steven presented
it beautifully it connected with my head
it hit my heart
how do i actually make that practical in
my day-to-day life i'm not stephen i'm
not jay how do i actually practically do
that and then finally what's the part
that i apply and take action on so as a
receiver of wisdom and knowledge you
have to do half that journey
all you can do is the theoretical and
the meaningful and you may even help
with practical tips and application but
someone still has to sit there and go
how do i do that unless you're sitting
there with them one-on-one obviously and
you can't do the the practical bit for
someone else forever ever yeah you could
maybe help them today or tomorrow
totally not for a lifetime it's not
going to be the fishing rod
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast is one of
the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddy right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
over the years i've tried to kind of
simplify what happiness is and i sit
here with my guests and mogada was great
at that as well yeah of course is
unbelievable
kind of the concept of happiness what
are the kind of simple fundamentals that
jay shetty requires in his life to live
a happy
life i'm going to use the word happy i
know it's a shitty word in many respects
but i just want to use that as the
the word yeah i'd say that i look at
happiness as
daily habits
and then
deeper purpose
so there's things you can do daily
that keep that happiness kind of moving
and feel it's growing and then there's
almost the objective the compass the
reason why you live and why you exist
and for me
it's been really clear that
finding your passion and using it in the
service of others
is what creates the greatest deepest
happiness
when you find what you love what you
excel at what you're brilliant at and
then you can actually use that
to improve people's lives and you can
use that skill that passion that energy
to make a difference in someone's life
there is no better feeling than that and
what i find is i meet a lot of people
who've mastered their passion
but not for service they mastered it for
business they mastered it for money they
are mastered it for success
and they have all of that but they
haven't got the service element in their
life they don't understand how to use
their passion for a purpose
and so they feel unequipped and then i
know lots of people are trying to serve
or trying to make a difference or trying
to do charity work they're trying to do
all this good work
and they feel good about it but they
still don't feel fulfilled because
they're missing what is my special role
like what's my position what's my
offering in this space you kind of get
lost after a while
and so to me happiness is where both
come together where it's like i know
what i love and what makes me happy
and when i do that for others to improve
their lives it makes them happy so if
you can do what makes you happy and do
it for others and it makes them happy
that's going to give you happiness and i
have tested that principle time and time
again with clients with friends with
family with myself and i've seen it to
be true again and again and again
but that's that bigger happiness piece
let's go to the daily habits like the
daily stuff and i want to try and avoid
the stuff that i think people have heard
and people have probably come across
before in many different places maybe
i've spoken about that maybe other
people have
but one of the biggest ones for me is i
read a book a few years ago about flow
state and that book really transformed
how i felt about things
and it talks about how being in flow
is the intersection
where your skills and your challenge
match
so if your skills are higher than your
challenge you'll feel bored lethargic
and maybe feel stuck
but if your challenge is greater than
your skills you feel overwhelmed
potentially depressed and disconnected
and disappointed
so most of us are living in one of those
discrepancies
and i find on a daily basis i'm playing
around with that equation for happiness
because that flow state of when you know
you have a skill and your challenge is
met and even if you lose you still get
such a joy out of it because you know
that you're still working in the right
direction and i think that is an
underplayed part of happiness
because it doesn't sound like something
predictable or obvious because people go
well that's achievement that's ambition
it's actually not it's just saying
for most people it's either or their
challenges are greater than their skill
or their skills greater than their
challenge so i would ask everyone to say
look at your life
do you need to improve your skills or do
you need to broaden your challenge is
this a year of expanding your challenges
or is this a year of broadening your
skills and i promise you if you start
with that you're going to get so busy
and active
changing one of those the happiness is
going to naturally flow
this comes into a little little model i
created of creating happiness for my
year
and
that one sits in one of them so i'll
explain which one it's in
i believe that to create happiness day
to day in one year in one month in a
week
you have to have
three things
you have to learn something every year
you have to launch something every year
and you have to love something every
year
and that's how i've lived for the last
three to five years every year i'm
learning something
every year i'm launching something and
every year i'm loving something and i'll
give you an example so when i talk about
flow state
that comes into the idea of raising your
challenge
is like launching something the reason
why launching something creates
happiness is because it creates a
feeling of nervousness it creates a
feeling of butterflies creates a feeling
of excitement like i don't know what's
going to happen we all need a feeling of
surprise in life we all need that
feeling of i don't know the sense of the
unknown can actually cause happiness
and so
launching something is such a powerful
way and i think too many people will
think for five years and think for ten
years and maybe launch one thing in
their whole life
and me and you but i mean i'd love to i
can't wait to interview on my podcast
but
i have launched so much stuff there
but that launch creates so much joy it
creates so much happiness so launch
something and we can dive into that then
there's
learn something which is what we just
talked about learning a skill so that's
the
that's the idea of creating your flow
state by saying what skill do i want to
learn and every year i pick a skill
and it's usually based on what i want to
launch the next year so i'll go okay i
need to learn podcasting so 2018 i
studied podcasting 2019 we launched the
podcast uh so what you learn turns in
what to what you launch and what you
launch turns into what you love
and what we try and do is we try and do
it the other way around we try and love
something before we learn and launch it
it doesn't make sense you've got to
learn about something first
and then you can fall in love with it
you can't love something and then learn
about it you can but it doesn't always
work that way so i try and plan my years
out in that way i go what am i going to
learn what am i going to launch and what
am i going to love so
yeah i think that's how i try and create
happiness on a daily weekly monthly
basis without diving into things like
gratitude and meditation which are huge
parts of my daily happiness but i think
those are ideas that are out there and
that we've talked about before probably
and you've launched a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff and uh we're going to
talk a little bit about some of those
things that you've launched i mean
you've got your your genius community
which you which has been going for a
long time now brilliant
a really brilliant business and really a
standout business in this whole industry
in terms of the way you um executed it
and the i mean even the design of the
the programs and i mean i remember going
on the website and trying to thinking to
myself
would i be able to make something as
quality as this um in the future and i'm
sort of modeling myself on that you've
got your certification school for
coaches as well you've launched your tea
business and there's also
a really i guess this is a bit of an
exclusive your partnership with calm the
mindfulness meditation app and i think
they also call themselves a sleep app as
well now i think that's a more modern um
description of them
so why did you partner with calm
so michael and i uh michael is one of
the co-founders of calm he's been on
this podcast yes exactly yes and uh we
we got introduced probably around
four years ago now
and he came over for lunch to my place
we were
hanging out connecting getting to know
each other he was being told that he
should really connect with me and i was
being told i should connect with him and
finally we got together so we had lunch
in my home my wife made us this
incredible lunch uh and we sat down and
he brought brought a friend and i had a
couple of people there and we just hung
out
and
in that meeting
i met someone who i really believed was
not trying to build an app
and i met someone who's not trying to
build a platform
and i met someone who was not trying to
build technology
he was trying to build an experience he
was trying to build a journey for people
to go on he was trying to build
a practical daily habit for each and
every single person in the world and
that was really beautiful for me to hear
because i'd been an admirer of calm when
it first started out and i first heard
about it probably
eight years before we met and i've been
seeing what they were doing and creating
and to meet the person behind it and for
them to be
as genuine sincere and wonderful as
michael is you've met him so you know
what he's like
i was really blown away by that i was
just blown away by that vision
and
having spent hours and years meditating
in the monastery and then meditating
afterwards i've always wanted to
share meditation at scale with the world
i think it's
a habit that 80 to 90 of the world's
most healthy wealthy and successful
people
live by
so if we could make it accessible
practical and relevant to each and every
person's daily life
can you imagine the transformation that
they'll have
and i've experienced that as a monk i
saw it in for years and years and years
i've seen it last year during the
pandemic i
went live for 20 days on instagram
and taught meditation just to everyone
and anyone because
i felt quite inadequate i was like i'm
not a frontline worker i can't save
lives i'm not a delivery person i'm not
helping people with their groceries and
their food i was like what can i offer
and i thought well maybe if people can
have
a minute of peace and calm then then
that might be worth it and across 40
days i ended up doing 40 instead of 20
across 40 days with 20 million people
tuned in and it was just so mind-blowing
to me and most of the people were saying
they'd never meditated before
and i thought to myself how beautiful
that was and one of the biggest pieces
of feedback i get from my audience is
well jay we want to meditate with you
every day
why can't we keep doing that and i was
like wow those 40 days of live
meditations were really intense and a
lot of work went into them
so i wanted a home
for where i could share meditation
every single day
a new piece of meditation insight that
each and every single person could build
a daily habit every day every day what
of seven minutes a day you're gonna do
seven minutes a day every day seven
minutes a day every day wow five days a
week five days a week not weekends you
get days off yeah everyone gets two days
off you don't have to meditate on the
weekends you can sleep in but you're
gonna you've recorded a meditation
income
for 365. we haven't recorded all again
we haven't recorded all of them because
they're fresh and they're moving and
they're based on my weekly inspiration
so we record them monthly nice so we
record them monthly so i've recorded for
the next month ahead because i have to
because everyone's going to need them
but i'm
basing it on like what my inspiration is
that week and what my day is that week
but it's a seven minute meditation and i
truly believe that everyone can find
seven minutes
and if everyone could just find seven
minutes in their day in their calendar
as i said that they put aside for
themselves i believe in those seven
minutes everyone could build a beautiful
habit now the difference with our
meditation is the meditations we've
created we believe they're meditations
that inspire action
so all of them are not just sitting
there on your own with yourself
breathing they're interconnected with a
change in your daily behavior so each
and every single one of them have a
takeaway have an insight that you can go
and apply no matter what you do across
the world
so the goal is when meditation meets
action where meditation can actually
help you
change how you feel that day through
your real life and so why i chose calm
was i wanted a home
i wanted to work with michael and the
team who i just believe are
dreaming
beautifully about how to bring
meditation to the world and so sincerely
and genuinely care about each and every
person
and i just love how
i would say i love how universally
they approach meditation
i think they approach meditation in this
universal expansive abundant mindset way
which makes story be a part of
meditation which makes visualization be
a part of meditation and that's how i
was trained in meditation as a monk so
it feels very philosophically aligned as
well
you know you've done so much
and really from what i
observed even
you really started in 2000 and i'd say
the the sort of external social media
content journey started in 2016. yes
that is mad
that is mad you've gone from
2016 um
making your first content tour in 2022
now just and you're this global
household name as it relates to content
self-improvement meditation all of these
topics right that's a short period of
time when you look back and you try and
connect the docs as steve jobs often did
about how apple came to be in the little
moments and the little things whether it
was a moment of um good fortune or
whether it was something that you have
spotted in hindsight in your character
why was jay shetty successful in such a
short period of time in such a big way
give me the honest practical answer i
don't want anything i want why why were
you successful so i'm going to give you
the i'm going to give you my monk answer
and then i'm going to give you then i'm
going to give the media answer so and
and i live by both right like you have
to you have to see things as both and
that's why i love
my monk answer is
i was really fortunate to meet
incredible people when i was young i met
a few people that absolutely transformed
my life
i'm eternally indebted to them grateful
to them and
i owe it all to them and so i give all
my success to them you know without
meeting
those amazing mentors and those
phenomenal thought leaders and thinkers
who are not famous who are not known who
are not
present like they're not they're not in
the social media world they're not big
names or whatever
those people you know those people
if i never met them none of this would
have happened i can see that's the
emotion in your face when you say this
yeah i just i i really you know we we
skipped it earlier but i i just feel
like
the gratitude that i have for
people who saw potential in me when i
didn't see it in myself
that is just the greatest gift you can
give to someone like i today have
self-awareness and i have confidence and
i know who i am and i i wasn't always
like that like there were tons of years
where i was insecure and
you know i was bullied for being
overweight and i was bullied for being
the only indian at school and there was
so much like baggage to do with just
my body my how the language i used and
all this kind of stuff and to
to have someone notice that you may have
something
i mean you've had that and that is just
you you like honor that person for the
rest of your life and the best thing is
those people don't even want it so you
know the best thing about all of this is
the people there are not going oh yeah
we did that they're they're actually
saying no no it's not us like it's you
and and i think that's the beauty of
that so i i have to say that it's
important that i share that answer
not because i'm trying to
give a more strategic answer but i think
it's important because it is a big part
of it
and so that would be the monks that i
met it would be the coaches that i met
the guys that i met looking at it from a
very practical strategic standpoint
shifting now
my parents forced me to go to public
speaking and drama school when i was 11
years old
and
i really didn't want to go because i was
shy
i was unconfident i was insecure about
being on stage or being in a public
setting i actually loved acting growing
up i really enjoyed acting and doing
theater and things like that where i was
playing another character but being
myself on stage
that was the last thing i wanted to do
and my parents saw that and they saw
that as something that i should work on
so they forced me and my school to
enroll me in a public speaking course
so from the age of 11 through to the age
of 18
for three hours a day three days a week
so nine hours a week for seven years i
went to public speaking school really
for seven years of my life i went to
public speaking school
so when i look back at my ability to
communicate my ability to understand
ideas and by the way public speaking
school is examination based too so we
had exams where they would give you a
topic 15 minutes before you have 15
minutes to research a topic from the
books in the room that they give you
because there was no smartphone at the
time when we were 11 12 years old
and you'd have to create a speech in 15
minutes about that subject from the
books that were in the room
you had to read from a book that you'd
never read before they'd pick a random
page and they'd ask you to read it out
so the examination of a public and this
was at the london academy of music drama
and arts it's called lambda
and that's where i studied for seven
years so
that's a very
strategic skill set that i had the time
to develop thanks to my parents you know
like without my parents that none of
that would have ever happened and i
think that's a big part of why people
hopefully appreciate how i communicate
ideas because i've spent a lot of time
understanding communication
but when i was 18 i had nothing to talk
about
so even though i had all these tools and
skills i didn't really use them because
i didn't care about anything so sure i
gave a good presentation at university
and work experience and an internship
but it was never something that brought
me to life
and so then when i met the monks and i
got an opportunity to study the vedas
which are 5 000 years old and again we
were put through rigorous study we sat
down we had to learn verses we had to
analyze purports commentaries on ancient
scriptures we had to do comparative
analysis of religions and tradition like
when i was a monk we were massively
trained in philosophical analysis
and that to me gave me a real strength
and confidence in these ideas so some of
the ideas i present today that may sound
simple they're based on these really
ancient deep truths
that i've had the time to
grapple with with the greats who really
understand them so that to me is a big
benefit i've had where i've had three
years
of
complete dedication to studying
philosophy and not just studying the
intellectual areas but the practical and
the applicable areas as well so thanks
to my monk teachers who gave me that
and then when i went to accenture
where people were like jay you're just a
monk why did you go to accenture i had
to pay the bills i couldn't rely on my
parents and you know my parents are not
wealthy that they could pay my way
through life and i moved back into there
i moved back into my childhood bedroom
when i was 26 wow living with my parents
with 25 000 18 000 pounds worth of debt
and just feeling that
you know i was like what do i do now and
i applied to 40 companies
that would have given me a job i'm a
first class honours degree student i'm a
straight a student
and i was rejected from 40 companies
because surprise surprise no one wanted
to hire a monk so everyone goes what are
your transferable skills sitting quietly
and sitting on the floor like no one
needs that so 40 companies say no to me
accenture finally give me a shot
and i meet someone called thomas power
and thomas power i don't know if you
ever met him actually he's london-based
uh he started up like an early linkedin
kind of version called academy and he
was he's very networked in london in the
business space definitely want to
introduce you guys he's awesome uh and
he was brought in by accenture to train
us in social media
and train us in in this new wave of this
new thing that was happening
and it's really interesting because
we've talked about it me and him many
times i'm going to have him on my
podcast soon
and i realized i was like you didn't
really teach me much about social media
but you really taught me about
breaking my mindset and he would always
repeat napoleon hill you become what you
think about and he'd always tell me that
i'd be like keep saying that to yourself
and i keep saying that to myself and you
become what you think about you become
and then i was like oh what am i
thinking i'm not thinking about anything
so what am i going to become nothing
and it was just really interesting so he
would give me these little tools and
little things to play with he had
another one called
ors which he would say that successful
people have to be open random and
supportive
and he'd say that most unsuccessful
people are closed selective and
controlling csc and he was saying that
when you live in a csc mindset you limit
your growth but when you live in an ors
mindset open random and supportive you
expand your growth so you'd encourage me
to be open with strangers on twitter it
encouraged me to be open with random
people with me at a conference and he
was just training me in behaviors and
mindsets
it wasn't like how to post and what time
to post and this is how you make it
wasn't how to make something go viral
like that wasn't it it was how to engage
how to push your comfort zone how to
challenge your fear why are you so
uncomfortable to walk up to that person
and tweet them you know all of those
kind of things
and i saw that my mind just became
just open to the idea so he would always
tell me you're an entrepreneur i'd be
like no i'm not no i'm not meant to work
for someone and so he would keep pushing
me until i'd get really angry with him
like you don't even know who i am
only for me to realize he saw something
in me that i never saw
and then i'd say from there on
that's kind of what gets me to the
beginning of it i would say that for 10
years before 2016
i was making content and delivering it
in small venues in london so i had an
event in london at university called
think out loud every single week i would
design a poster on photoshop i taught
myself photoshop and i'd make a poster
and i would talk about a movie from a
philosophical psychological and
spiritual perspective so i take a movie
like inception and i'd break it down and
10 students would come every week and
then i teach meditation which i'd
learned from the monks and then 20
students would come and by the time i
finished university 100 people came
every single week to hear me break down
and this was no followers the events
were free i was preparing for free doing
everything for free and i loved it and i
got so much joy and then afterwards when
i was accenture i ran an event in london
called conscious living
and it was just a it was an event which
was probably like five pound on a friday
night and again i was teaching
philosophy spirituality and meditation
and i was lucky if five people turned up
it wasn't university anymore where you
could go and deck the halls with flyers
and posters in the common room and the
community area so we'd get like five to
ten people every friday night paying
five to ten quid just for the food that
we gave and you know the posters that we
made just to cover the costs
so for ten years before i ever made a
piece of content online
i've practiced rehearsed
experimented
grappled
challenged these ideas again and again
and again and again and again
without any followers without any money
and without anything else coming from it
apart from the fact that i love it i
love the idea of reading a book and
trying to make it relevant so i would
say that the biggest reason is because
i've done this for 10 years offline
before i ever went online so i've been
doing it for like 16 years and that
doesn't count the
11 year old public speaking classes
it's really there's something really
beautiful about that because it i think
it gives them a sense of it's incredibly
inspiring but it also gives a sense of
peace to people who are at stage in
their journey where they're sat on the
phones in a call center selling i don't
know double glazing like i was and
they're thinking
um this is a waste of time
they're thinking picking up this phone
and trying to persuade margaret to buy
some windows is a waste of time and it's
not serving my where i want to go and
it's only in hindsight when you speak to
people like yourself or you hear about
steve jobs journey or really anybody
that sits here on this podcast
yeah like so those are some of the most
unbelievably formative and most pivotal
experiences as it relates to
the thing you will go on to do and you
never know when that's going to happen
right you never know when
opportunity is going to meet preparation
in your life totally and that also
speaks to something you said earlier
which is it's about the mindset you have
when you're doing those things and if
you believe i think if you believe that
sitting on that phone is going to be the
rest of your life forever
you're increasing the chances of that
being the case and i'm not putting down
people that do center jobs it's actually
one of my one of my favorite and the job
i did the longest um
but i just think that's such an
important mindset shift that can inspire
and not demotivate yeah i think we have
to look at our life as a series of
things that add up each other rather
than like this is a waste this is a
waste and that's not a waste and by the
way you said call center that sparked a
memory i had a internship when i was 16
years old
at the business design center in angel
and i was working for a company called
upper street events that sold
event space to companies for these big
exhibitions and events that happened in
the venue
and i remember at 16 having to call up
nissan bmw vw audi
vauxhall etc because they're doing a big
car exhibition now by the way i was a 16
year old kid
who didn't really know i was doing but
the people trained me really well and i
would i was cold calling and i
completely agree with you i think that
gave me so much confidence to be able to
pick up the phone to anyone and everyone
to tweet anyone and everyone to dm
anyone and everyone by the way cristiano
ronaldo has the longest list of dms from
me that he's never seen right he has the
longest list of dm's for me that he's
never seen but i'm hoping that one day
he's going to see them and i'm going to
get to interview him and it's the idea
of like i don't i'm not worried if he
doesn't see them i'm not upset if one
day he sees 30 dms from me
because i know that that's what it takes
and i'm okay with that there's no ego
there i'm so happy if christina went out
to open it up and saw oh this guy's
desperate
i would take that all day because i
think he's a i think he has a phenomenal
mind and i would love to sit down with
him what did you lose
what did you lose right but that comes
from when you're cold calling in the
call center
you learn that mindset of what did i
lose if this person said no
and there's 300 people on this list
and that person might be the one that
wants it now and that person might come
back around and you get to develop those
skills so
i just i just hope that wherever you are
listening to this right now wherever
you're watching it
you just take a moment to realize that
that place can teach you everything you
need to know about your purpose and if
you just approach it in that way you're
going to walk to work with a pep in your
step and like this energy that's going
to be so electric and so magnetic that
everyone's going to know what's going on
with you and all it is is that you're
looking at life as an addition rather
than a subtraction and you'll receive in
a completely different way right correct
yeah we have a long-standing tradition
on this podcast um where the previous
guest writes a question for the next
guest in the diary that's genius
i love that new addition
the reason why we did it and i've never
really explained this is we want to
basically connect
the the episodes together and the guests
together in some way and doing that
by a question written in the diaries our
way um
who came up with that great idea it's
brilliant it's absolutely fantastic i'm
going to tell my team
it's funny because this question is
actually one i think i asked you already
so you can ask me another one if you
want you can pick a pick a random one
yeah i can just make one up no um so the
question asked what is your
definition
of true
success
i'd say my definition of true success
is that
there are four important decisions we
make in our life
and if you can make every
decision intentionally
with the desire to
learn and serve
then that's all you can do
so the four most important decisions we
make in our life are how do i feel about
myself
what do i do for money
who do i give my love to
and how do i serve others
and if you spend your life focusing on
intentionally making those choices
then your life is a success
because all you can do is try to live
intentionally and
try to hope that it helps other people
amen
listen jay i can't thank you enough for
coming here and doing this um i know you
are a very in demand very um a very very
successful man who's who's only in the
uk for a short period of time so it's a
true honor that you would come here and
sit with me and have this conversation
for me you've been a real role model in
many many ways and you know you've led
the way in the the content the
self-development the helping people
change their lives domain especially as
someone that comes from the same country
as me for the longest time so i've
always looked looked at you for the last
i don't know seven years since i've i've
started doing this and i think your
success has propelled and enabled mine
from a point of inspiration but also
from giving me a blueprint on how to
serve so i've never got to say that to
you before but i really want to say
thank you because that's um you know
you've helped you're probably the reason
i get to help people as well in my own
way so that means you know it means a
ton to me that you would come here and
sit with me and uh yeah it's just thank
you that is probably one of the most
humbling things anyone's ever said to me
because i'm a huge fan of the podcast i
think you do an incredible job and i
think you have some amazing guests
guests that i've never sat down with or
you know may not be in my ra
my radar or radius and you've
shared things with them that have just
been phenomenal
and so when i'm listening and watching i
want to get my haircut yeah i was
talking to my um hairdresser about you
and i was like i'm going this podcast
tomorrow and and you know and he and he
listens to you as well and knows who you
are
and
and i was just like yeah and the the
easiest thing that came back to me was
just yeah stephen's a really nice guy
like he's really down to earth he's
really humble and i find that phenomenal
because of your age because of what
you've achieved
i've never felt like even
a drop of ego around you
and whether that's in your online
presence whether that's when we met in
new york whether that's on twitter all
those years ago whether it's today
before we're on camera
and and i really appreciate that i think
as monks we were trained
that the most
admirable quality in a human is humility
like that was seen as like the the if if
we could say that in the material world
the highest thing about someone is
whatever it is
the currency in monk life was humility
and so when i meet people who have
humility i really they're like my
they're like the people that i get drawn
to the most
and and you just have it in bags for and
i i just think you're
gonna go off and do
even more incredible successful
phenomenal things for the world and i'm
excited to watch i'm excited to be a fan
a friend
and hopefully we get to do stuff
together too but uh this was beautiful
man thank you so much thank you thank
you for having me i wanted to come on
this is this is beautiful this is
brilliant i hope we hope we do it more
and i can't wait to have you one i'm
very excited
now that you're coming to l.a
we're gonna have you on it's gonna be
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you